hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
expression purification and
characterization
of difficult to express membrane
proteins in the xc 293
and xp cho expression systems presented
by dr anastahri
chief scientific officer callixer
i'm christy joel of flabbers and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
this presentation is brought to you by
labyrinths and sponsored by thermo
fisher scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermofisher.com
the presentation you are about to see
was previously recorded
but i would like to remind you that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
quick question box
and click send dr jahari
will answer the questions via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers free continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i would like to introduce today's
speaker dr anash johari
chief scientific officer calixer dr
jahari holds a phd in biochemistry and
structural biology
from louis pasteur university in
strasbourg
france obtained under the supervision of
professor dino mora
he worked as a research associate at the
scripps research institute in la jolla
california and epigene center in munich
germany
prior to joining transgene as research
investigator
he is now chief scientific officer at
calixer he has more than 18 years
experience in research and development
projects
related to molecular aspects of vaccine
cancer
and infectious diseases dr jahari is
also a member of different membrane
protein consortiums
gpcr and ion channels and a board member
of different institutions including soj
immunology editorial in the united
states and chem to staff consortium in
france
to view dr jahari's biography please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr jahari's presentation will now begin
okay so thank you very much for the
introduction and
thank you for the chance to present some
of the work
we have been doing lately so i will not
be uh
talking about um
exclusively the work we do at calixar
but i will really rather be reporting on
the recent
outcome of a collaborative effort that
we have together with the thermofisher
scientific
so of course it deals with the
expression or difficult to express
membrane proteins
since they are extremely important for
drug discovery
um i will focus in one case study to
actually tell you a little bit more what
what kind of
take home message we can get out of that
um
so the focus of the presentation is is
basically a little bit
described here so we'll be talking about
strategies to optimize
expression levels of membrane proteins
using the xp293 and xp cho
expression systems will also
tell you a little bit about the new
developed xp 293 that
our colleagues at thermofisher are
developing
and this have something to do with the
inducible and gnti
minus engineered cell line there's
something wrong with the microphone
so i will tell you also how we are using
kalixar patented technology to evaluate
the quality and the quantity of the
challenging membrane proteins we
we express something which is extremely
important
is not only to express or to overexpress
it's to overexpress
healthy protein what we want at the end
is not to have tons of aggregated
protein
but it's half milligrams of high quality
proteins and this is why
the collaboration between calixar and
thermofisher is actually
nice because we are combining expertise
sorry okay so um the focus of the
presentation will all be
like i said we'll be focusing on kcc2
which is one of the
key proteins in drug discovery and this
is why
we are collaborating on on that so kcc2
is a norm
specific potassium chloride called
transporter that controls neural
accurate homostasis and it's absolutely
required for
involving different neurological
disorders
including brain trauma epilepsy autism
and schizophrenia
kcc2 is absolutely need to be
glycosylated
and also phosphorylated to be active and
we have been
describing basically this
topological structure with different
glycans and different phosphorylation
that we could actually identify in this
paper that i will recite very often in
this presentation
so it's it's a it's a it's really a nice
target for this
assessment because it needs to be
glycosylated and need to be
uh post freshly modified and the systems
we are using xp 293 and
xp show joe cells are actually
known to be able to do that so
let's have a look to uh some of the data
so what we wanted to start
by doing is to a screen xp 293 and xp
short cells in term of expression on
this target so
uh this is not a nice gel i wouldn't
show you better ones but typically this
protein
migrates as in different species one of
the species is um so two
two uh glycan forms and then one dimeric
form that is difficult to dissociate in
sds page
so we have looked in two different
parameters one of the parameter is the
type of vector
this one is under cmv promoter and the
other one is in their ef1
alpha promoter we looked into different
dna amounts we looked into
like i said already two cell lines xp2
and 3 and xp
show cells two temperatures and then we
also performed
work on two construct and terminus
tagged and citaminous stacks
the take-home message is that obviously
we get better expression
in these conditions xp293 and also using
the
cmv promoter and 32 degrees so this this
is not
extremely surprising because our
colleagues
at thermal working with soluble protein
gets also similar tendencies
so it does not mean that you don't get
expression um
in short cells but you just get less
expression
more xp choices so
uh one thing i wanted to point out is
the
amount of all the ratio of protein
expressed as a plasma membrane
here versus internal membrane so we have
worked previously and we published this
paper
two years ago where we could see that
fifty percent
of of the kcc2 is actually present in
the plus membrane and the other half of
it
it's present and internal membranes so
uh this is not surprising we have shown
this
when you are using classical hex cells
now what is interesting is
when you actually move to xp293 and you
express the same protein
in with the n-terminus tag or a ct minus
tag
you get somehow better expression in the
plasma membrane so the ratio is somehow
changing
you get better expression plus membrane
in comparison to antenna membranes
so this was true for antennas construct
cetaminous construct
in but it's also the same
thing when you work with xp chosen so
you have pretty much the same tendencies
so um yeah so better ratio of kcc2 plus
my versus internal
membranes for xp 293 and xp2 in
comparison to
classical ancestor which is heck 293
so and this was what we published
previously so we therefore focus
on the internal tag because we have
shown in the past
in collaboration with astrazeneca that
when the protein is tagged on the c
terminus it's actually not
functional so something is wrong when
you add
even the short tag on the stimulus so
therefore we focus only on antiminus tag
to be able to assess basically the
quality of what we express later on
so this is where we are using a
candidates our
approach which is basically a patented
technology um
using non-denaturated process to avoid
different aspects like refolding
metagenesis and
and and still have an impact on the
stability of the protein
and maintain functional and structural
integrities
so this is um i don't have time to go
into detail but this is
using primary compounds and um
and combination of those compounds to
not only solubilize but in the meantime
stabilize i think this is one of the
discussions we already had before
in one of the talks by an oxford
genomic consortium so the compounds we
come up with are some of them are listed
here so they have
different chemistry so in this case it's
callix orange arraign-based chemistry
so there are a couple of structures
there is a nice
well i cannot say nice because it's one
of our work
there is a review describing this in
more detail and there is a recent
paper showing how we could use these
compounds to actually stabilize
native gpcrs and then enable fragment
based stroke design
so i'll not talk about this now so but
there are also other
compounds that we came up with and they
are amphiphilic compounds not
necessarily calyx rind based
some of them is this what we call clip
so they show really good stabilization
power on
gpcrs and transporters and there are
other ones that have
extremely different chemistry so don't
have time to go into the detail but this
is really
like a toolbox to allow us to assess
what do we express
uh together with our colleagues at
thermo fisher
so we have shown previously in this
paper that internal membranes protein
are extremely
or let's say kcc2 expressed in internal
membranes are extremely difficult to
extract
from those membranes so this is just a
dot blot um
in plasma membrane you can you can
easily extract the proteins
in internal membranes only the positive
control which is sds
work and the other ones are really lousy
extraction
so this was also the same result and
this was from hex cells right
so the same results we need the western
blot you see the soluble fraction you
have
nothing and the pellets everything is in
the pellet now when you work with
xp293 it seems that we are actually able
to solubilize the protein
which was not the case in hexanes so
even if we start from
internal membranes it's actually able
and we were able to sobalize the protein
that was actually the first time and the
first surprise
so basically kcc2 can be easily
extracted from antenna membranes which
is not the case in hexels
and this result should exist probably
that the kcc2 was in
better folding and then the same result
was also obtained
in the other cell line which is xp true
cells
now okay it's great you can solubilize
it you can you can um
you can express it um and stabilize it
but are we able to purify it so indeed
using and focus only on this construct
we could uh
you know purify it and this is a stain
free gel you could also by western blood
see that you have this double band
corresponding to
different glycan forms
and uh yeah so we could elude
specifically the protein so typically
kcc2 can be extracted and purified from
xp to 93 nicely
and this was form internal but also from
plasma membrane
it was from xp but also from cho cells
and this was in this case and the
interminus tag but
the ct minus also work the same so it's
really
nice to see that this is this expression
system
allowed to have a quite nice um purified
protein so now
how well folded is this protein so we
did um size exclusion chromatography and
native page and we could see that we
have monomers and dimers and this is not
surprising because that's what we
actually already established in this
manuscript uh
previously published so we could see
that we could separate the dimer
from the monomer by by gel filtration
and then evaluate that by
native page and uh also in the gel
filtration you can see that there is
nothing in the void volume so definitely
there are no aggregates and there are
obviously two populations
dimers and monomers and then if you look
into this population
in negative stain you see dimers and
monomers you could
even get some low resolution
reconstructions out of this negative
stain
pictures and yeah so we could show um
for the first time the organization of
this
transporter which is um kind of
highlight the function i would not
talk about this now because we don't
have time but typically
out of this xp 293 cell line we could
obtain pure
aggregate free kcc2 of course i'm
talking about human kcc2
and and this was the same result
starting from xp to cells
now our colleagues at thermo fisher
scientific they could develop a new
system to produce basically the xp 293 i
don't have all the detail but you are
more than welcome to talk to to them uh
they have a po
there is a poster uh to describe that
but typically
you could get much more expression using
this new system and this will be
probably launched i think
in a couple of months i will have to
check that with them but typically this
system allowed to obtain
more than you know four to five times
more protein
with the same quality so what we call
quality is basically at least
evaluate into a negative page what we
purify
so we have pretty much the same pattern
with in terms of monomers timers
presence and
no aggregates whatsoever in there
and also this was checked by jet
filtration as well
so and this is not always the case
because you know when you
uh overexpress the protein very often
you also generate more aggregate so
there is always a good correlation
between overexpression and aggregability
and obviously in this case it seems to
be quite healthy protein
gets more protein but it also gets
healthy proteins
okay and yeah so this healthy protein
allow us now to collect some
cryo electromicroscopy data so i show
you some low resolution maps
so i will not be showing you high
resolution maps today but we are
actually uh
still processing this data but
definitely thanks to the amount of
protein that we could obtain
and thanks to the high quality of the
protein that was expressed using
xp 293 system we could actually uh be
able to
concentrate the protein to six milligram
per ml and then you know um
dilute some of it to make to to to
prepare some uh
some craving grids and then there are
there are a couple of datasets that are
um
uh evaluated now so um
just a couple of um slides to show you
also a little bit of
uh innovation going on on the on the
on the glycosylation aspect so typically
and we have here that
before uh glycosylation is is important
for
function kcc2 when you treat it with
pnga you see that you have fast
migrating bands and this was
when you work with hexels so we have
shown this already in the past
so that's reason why uh at thermo fisher
they they basically tried to express
the xp 293 with the kcc2 and xp293
gnti minus cell line and obviously you
could see that you have these double
bands corresponding to classic c2
but then you have also lower band
corresponding
probably less complex glycan of gcc2
so now when you solubilize and purify
the protein
and then put that into a native page you
can again get
the same pattern which is monomers and
dimers but somehow
it shifted you know it migrates
more rapidly which show that probably we
have
populations that are less complex in
terms of glycosylation which is actually
extremely important
for um antibody discovery and
also of course for structural biology
because you get less heterogeneity and
then
for antibiotic discovery it can be
important because you can't
sorry get better accessibility of your
ap top of interest
and in terms of induction um this
is also in going work together with our
colleagues
so the idea is to try to tackle the
toxicity of some of the membrane
proteins some of the membrane proteins
are just toxic because some ion channels
for example start to interfere with the
metabolism
when you express them so having um
introducing this tet induction system in
xp293 can maybe address that
aspect of toxicity that reason why they
they could
start to induce using this
data induction system and interestingly
you see there is a good correlation
between the induction
and the amount of protein that is
expressed and
then if you stabilize this protein and
purify it then you also again
get similar patterns so that means it's
really
we are getting more protein but we are
also getting
good quality protein
so the theta induction system of
expisure entry is of high interest to
toxic proteins
i mentioned already such as ion channels
or transporters
it allowed to express and purify
aggregate-free protein and
recently um there is a combination there
is an idea of combining
that induction with the glycan
complexity reduction using the gti
minus and this is actually also
evaluated and we are part of
evaluators for this system that also
will be out of the
out available
and finally i want to conclude by
telling you what's
basically we could learn from this one
so mainly from kcc to work but also
including all the targets
uh what you could learn is that the pc
dna cmv promoter are no better
expression than the
pf1 one alpha it seems that xp 293
show better expression than the xp cho
cells at least for the membrane proteins
we looked at
there is obviously a better ratio in
term of kcc2 plus membrane versus
antenna membranes
and this is um in comparison to ancestor
which is heck
cells and the the kc2 was successfully
solubilized and purified
using calixor patented technology um
from internal membranes that was for the
first time actually we are able to
to do that from antenna membranes and
this was
not the case for excels probably
because there's a better fold i mean of
course this need to be evaluated
further but that's what we we have the
fee
we think it's it's the origin of this um
what we observe the expression yield um
and quality
enable now chrome em studies of kcc2
but it's gonna be the same for fragment
based draw design
and then also the same for antibody
discovery pretty much
because what they are in common what
they have in common is the quality of
the protein
so the same tendency were observed in
x-speed shore cells
and we also did
the same work with other constructs and
we could have the same tendencies with
other targets like sodium voltage
channels i
don't talk about this in detail so the
modifications of xp-8293
expression system allow to have a much
better yield in term of
protein without compromising the quality
and then finally
the gnti and the inducible system of xp
293 allow to reduce glycogen complexity
and modulate cases of expression
respectively and this
will be something to evaluate also in
combination and then
finally i would like to say that xp293
and xp
cho cells offer really a nice
opportunity to overexpress
difficult to express membrane protein
not only to overexpress them but to
express
and allow to purify healthy protein
because that's the goal at the end
so and finally i would like to thank
people that were involved in this work
so
our colleagues are thermo fisher
scientific so that are
some of them are in the audience uh
please contact them directly if you want
to learn more about
the sea lions and there is also a poster
describe this in more detail sorry i'm
going back
and then uh and this poster is a 100
so it's the title is indicated here and
then some of my um
people from from my team that are listed
here that
really were involved in this very
interactive collaboration
and thank you very much for your
attention and happy to take questions
a big thank you goes out to dr jahari
for his excellent presentation
now if you do have any questions you
would like to ask dr jahari
please type them into the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and click send
dr jahari will be answering questions
via the email address you provided
at the time of registration
we would like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
you will now be redirected to the
registration page of our next webinar
factor five expression in xp cho cells
presented by dr laurel monier on
november
7th at 9 am pacific standard time
we hope to see you there